mes chers collègues madame la rapporteur
après avoir entendu le ministre de la
Santé Monsieur François Braun que vous
venez de croiser
nous poursuivons cette séquence finale
des travaux de notre commission
d'enquête sur la pénurie de médicaments
et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française en auditionnant
de nouveau madame
Christelle Ratinier et carbonée donc les
directrice générale de l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
des produits de santé
accompagné de madame Carole le Saunier
qui est directrice réglementation et
déontologie de monsieur Guillaume Renaud
directeur de l'inspection et de Monsieur
Pierre Olivet responsable du centre
d'appui aux situations d'urgence aux
alertes sanitaires et à la gestion des
risques
fort bien je pense que vous êtes à la
bonne audition
nous vous avions reçu madame le 15
février dernier en préambule ou presque
de nos travaux c'était le début et cette
première audition nous avait permis de
couvrir dans toute sa diversité le chant
des politiques publiques qui au problème
qui nous réunit et dont nous souhaitons
la résolution prochaine à savoir celui
du caractère désormais chronique dans le
quotidien des patients français des
pénuries de médicaments et
chronique dans le temps et depuis de
nombreuses années mais chronique tous
les hivers au moment des épidémies
olivernales parce qu'au bout de 10
années de pénurie de corticoïdes en
gouttes on peut considérer qu'on est
aussi dans la chronicité vous êtes en
effet je le rappelle à directrice
générale de l'agence qui est notamment
chargée de recueillir les déclarations
de rupture et du risque de rupture émise
par les laboratoires pharmaceutiques et
de contrôler le respect des obligations
qui leur incombe en matière de
prévention et de gestion de telles
ruptures en fonctionnant d'éventuelles
quatre mois et demi après l'ouverture de
nos travaux nous vous auditionnons de
nouveau madame alors qu'ils sont sur le
point de s'achever vu la centralité de
l'agence que vous dirigez dans le
pilotage de la politique du médicament
ce qui nous a été confirmé tout au long
des auditions et fort désormais du recul
offert par 18 semaines d'audition de
déplacement et d'enquête et nous a paru
nécessaire en effet de vous réentendre à
l'aune des témoignages que nous avons
reçu dans cette intervalle et nous vous
remercions de vous être mobilisés de
nous étant donné l'ampleur et la
criticité d'un phénomène qui est très
loin de daté d'hier et compte tenu en
retour de l'ambition des annonces faites
hier par le Président de la République
la question se pose en particulier de
savoir si vos moyens et votre
dimensionnement sont appropriés à part
les tâches celles-ci supposant notamment
une capacité à bien cartographier les
chaînes de production et de distribution
du médicament et à traiter analyser de
nombreuses données et documents dont
l'agence est destinataire et notamment
en matière de contrôle de stock avec une
extension possible de ces stocks qui
nous a été annoncé hier de 2 à 4 mois
pour les médicaments la liste des 50
médicaments particulièrement
super critique on va dire ça comme ça
puisqu'on change de mot à peu près tous
les mois donc
on les a identifié comme tel en tout cas
je vais donc vous céder la parole madame
pour un bref propos introductif puis
madame Laurence Cohen rapporteur de
notre commission d'enquête vous posera
une première série de questions je
précise donc à nouveau que cette
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte-rendu publié et
avant de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devons
notre commission d'enquête et passive
des peines prévues aux articles 434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code je vous
invite à activer votre micro et après
décemment de dire toute la vérité rien
que la vérité en levant la main droite
et en disant je le jure
madame j'ai un truc monsieur Renaud je
ne sais pas si vous interviendrez mais
dans le doute non il y a que vous oui
d'accord très bien
parfait madame le directrice vous avez
la parole
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
Madame la rapporteur mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs merci beaucoup de donner
l'opportunité à nouveau à l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
des produits de santé que j'ai l'honneur
de diriger de pouvoir être auditionné
par par votre commission d'enquête vous
l'avez indiqué 18 semaines d'audition
j'ai suivi évidemment l'ensemble des
auditions et des comptes rendus donc
avec un panorama extrêmement extrêmement
large et qui témoigne en effet de la
complexité évidemment du sujet de son
caractère extrêmement multifactoriel
mais pour autant évidemment la nécessité
de trouver de trouver des mesures des
mesures à la fois en termes
d'anticipation de prévention et de
gestion des situations des situations de
tension et de pénurie sur sur le
médicament vous l'avez indiqué madame la
Présidente avec des annonces en effet du
président de la République sur la partie
notamment relocalisation et également la
publication et monsieur le ministre que
vous avez
auditionner juste avant a pu le a pu le
préciser avec la mise la mise en place
d'une liste de médicaments alors le
terme en tout cas consacré et publié on
parle de médicaments essentiels donc
voilà donc sur en tout cas voilà sur le
dossier le dossier en effet public voilà
liste de médicaments essentiels qui a
été le fruit en effet à notre travail à
la fois avec des sociétés savantes pour
définir en échelle la
nécessité d'un point de vue médical d'un
point de vue clinique de ces médicaments
et ensuite au sein de cette liste
d'identification de certains de certains
médicaments en effet et vous avez
utilisé le terme dit critique qui
présente un certain nombre de vues
vulnérabilités en termes de production
et qui ont permis en effet notamment
dans le cadre des annonces du président
de la République
ce mardi oui ça c'était mardi ce mardi
les les intentions en effet de
relocalisation juste quelques éléments
très bref pour resituer en effet le
panorama et la de la puissance publique
de longue date sur le sujet des pénuries
de médicaments au tout départ notamment
dans la loi de décembre 2011 avec les
premiers éléments en effet qui ont été
introduits notamment sur le sujet donc
de
sur le sujet en effet des pénuries et
ensuite au fur et à mesure notamment en
2016 et ensuite en 2020 avec donc un on
va dire un dispositif en effet de plus
en plus affiné nous avons aujourd'hui à
peu près 12000 spécialités qui sont
commercialisées sur le territoire
national et donc on est vraiment la
mobilisation en effet de de l'ensemble
des acteurs se fait je dirais sous forme
de poupées gigogne on a 12000
spécialités au global donc disponible
sur le territoire national il y en a à
peu près 6000 qui répondent à la
définition de médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur au sein de ces 6000
donc médicament d'intérêt petite majeur
la loi et vous et vous avez été
évidemment largement mobilisé madame la
rapporteur l'a rappelé dans dans la
précédente audition
il y a eu en effet des débats et des
échanges sur le niveau de stock et au
final le niveau de stock est de 2 et de
deux mois de stock de sécurité pour les
habiter m certains sont déjà à quatre
mois de stock de sécurité la loi ayant
consacrée cette possibilité cette
dérogation que je peux prendre qui est
donc à la main de la directrice générale
de la NSM sous réserve qu'il y a
l'identification de rupture de stock
dans les deux années civils précédents
et on a aujourd'hui un peu plus de 400
spécialités qui ont déjà quatre mois de
stock de sécurité ces spécialités se
retrouvent pour partie dans la liste des
médicaments essentiels donc des quatre
sens alors il est dit en effet liste des
médicaments essentiels 450 on parle bien
de dCi et donc de dénomination commune
internationale vous avez vu la liste
vous avez le paracétamol vous avez
l'amoxicilline derrière c'est dci vous
avez évidemment beaucoup plus de
spécialités en termes de présentation
exactement paracétamol par exemple
on a la DCI paracétamol vous avez des
formes morales vous avez des
formagesables des formes orales
notamment adultes on a à peu près 60
présentations donc en fait vous avez un
nombre de dci 400 de dénomination
commune internationale pardon vous avez
donc 450 et derrière vous avez un nombre
beaucoup plus important de spécialités
qui sont concernées donc on est bien en
entonnoir si Mélanie TM avec des stocks
de sécurité soit de 2 mois et pour
certains donc un petit peu moins de 10%
4 mois de stock de sécurité ensuite
cette liste de médicaments essentiels le
fruit du travail en effet avec les
sociétés savantes plus des décennies en
effet qui ont été ajoutés notamment dans
le cadre des plantes santé publique on a
les substituts nicotiniques on a les
vaccins notamment dans le cas de
l'obligation vaccinale on a également
les pilules abortives et les pilules du
lendemain si je donne quelques exemples
et donc là on est à 450 en effet dCi et
ensuite vous avez donc fruit du travail
aussi de l'identification des de ses
besoins thérapeutiques et de la
vulnérabilité des facteurs de
responsabilité en termes de production
une seule chaîne de production ou autre
une donc une une liste plus restrein
donc de 50 candidats potentiels pour la
relocalisation donc qui ont fait l'objet
des annonces du président de la
République donc on est bien dans ce
système d'entonnoir pour en effet être
attentif aux situations les plus à
risque possible ça c'est de manière
générale ensuite et vous l'avez vous
l'avez évidemment dit madame la
Présidente nous avons la situation
récurrentes notamment de pathologies
hivernale en effet tous les ans on sait
à peu près que à l'automne ou à l'hiver
on a des épidémies en effet des
épidémies hivernales qui sont qui sont
évidemment qui sont évidemment
importantes récurrentes et où nous
allons avoir une saisonnalité de la
consommation des produits de santé donc
de la consommation des médicaments il
est donc nécessaire et on l'a vu en
effet sur sur les mois passés il est
donc nécessaire en effet de pouvoir de
pouvoir anticiper et mettre en place un
plan de la question des tensions par
rapport à ces situations à ces
situations hivernales et c'est ce qui a
été et c'est ce qui est mobilisé et
quasiment je pense qu'il sera disponible
d'ici la fin du mois de juin début
juillet en tout cas c'est la commande
qui nous a été passée par le ministre
d'un plan de gestion en effet hivernal
de ces tensions sous l'égide de la NSM
donc qui est en co-construction avec
l'ensemble des partis prenantes avec
avec en effet une philosophie une
philosophie qui permet à d'emmener
l'ensemble des parties prenantes les
professionnels de santé les médecins les
pharmaciens mais également les patients
avec évidemment la une vision je dirais
assez classique d'un plan de gestion à
la fois une situation de veille donc un
niveau de veille celle que nous activons
déjà aujourd'hui un niveau en effet
d'anticipation et évidemment ensuite des
actions lorsque l'on est en situation en
situation évidemment complexe avec des
indicateurs qui sont en effet
donc multiples à la fois des indicateurs
épidémiologiques donc lorsque l'on voit
en effet l'augmentation des cas de
bronchiites l'augmentation des cas de
grippe ou d'autres ou d'autres
situations où par exemple le covid des
indicateurs en effet quantitatifs de
suivi en termes d'approvisionnement et
des indicateurs ensuite de terrain pour
avoir les remontées terrain donc avec
des sentinelles pharmaciens et médecins
dans les territoires puisque vous l'avez
évidemment déjà souligné il y a une
iniquité une hétérogénéité plus
exactement à ce stade une hétérogénéité
sur sur le territoire et c'est et donc
avec une mobilisation avec les airs et
donc c'est dans ce cadre là que le plan
hivernal en effet est mobilisé donc qui
est une étape avant le plan blanc dont
le ministre en effet a pu a pu parler à
la précédente à la précédente en effet
audition ou vraiment l'objectif est on
va dire de septembre à mars ou avril
après nous verrons il y a la
mobilisation de ce plan à la fois une
boîte à outils qui permet de mobiliser
tout ce que l'on peut pour essayer de
limiter au maximum les situations les
situations de tension et je termine mes
propos liminaires il y a évidemment le
sujet des approvisionnements vous en
avez parlé de la cartographie de la
situation et on ne peut agir en effet
sur la garantie de la couverture des
besoins sanitaires de nos concitoyens
sans parler du bon usage puisque nous
avons une spécificité très française
nous sommes très gros consommateurs de
médicaments et il y a un sujet en effet
de bon usage de juste utilisation du
médicament ni trop peu ni trop mais
vraiment au bon niveau au bon équilibre
et c'est dans ce cadre que j'espère que
vous l'avez déjà tous vu nous avons
lancé la NSM a lancé la campagne de
communication sur le bon peut-être ou
pas je ne sais pas sur sur le bon usage
donc qui a été lancé la semaine dernière
mais c'est ça parce que nous sommes
jeudi la semaine dernière donc
repositionnant en effet le médicament
comme voilà les médicaments ne sont pas
des produits ordinaires ne pas à la
légère donc interpellant en effet chacun
sur notre reconnaissance sur le
médicament et la nécessité en effet de
recourir au conseil d'un professionnel
de santé avant d'utiliser évidemment un
médicament donc ça c'est aussi un point
majeur les deux doivent aller de pair à
la fois évidemment la garantie de
l'approvisionnement et des de la
couverture des besoins pour les patients
mais également la juste utilisation qui
est un point majeur on y reviendra
j'imagine peut-être notamment sur
l'exemple des antibiotiques merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente
merci beaucoup je passe la parole à
Laurence cohenrapporter
toutes ces questions
oui
si madame la Présidente merci Madame
pour pour vos propos introductifs donc
effectivement nous avons eu juste avant
vous l'audition du ministre de la Santé
et puis il y a eu donc des déclarations
concernant et vous l'avez redit dans vos
votre propos
liminaires sur ces 450 médicaments
essentiels alors au regard de votre
connaissance du secteur et contenu des
pratiques en fait que vous observez chez
les industriels est-ce qu'il vous paraît
pertinent d'exiger des entreprises pour
certains médicaments des stocks
supérieurs à quatre mois puisque nous au
niveau du Sénat nous avions d'abord
légiférer pour qu'il y ait d'ailleurs
des stocks à 4 mois à ce moment-là
c'était le ministre Véran qui était aux
commandes et ça a été ramené à deux mois
là on voit donc à nouveau il y a une
réflexion contenue de ce que nous vivons
pénurie etc mais il peut y avoir y
compris des stocks supérieurs à quatre
mois donc d'où d'où ma question
ma deuxième question ça concerne vous
l'avez un peu dit les plans de gestion
de pénurie normalement donc il y a un
décret le décret de mars 2021 qui
prévoit de tenir compte des risques
relatifs aussi de fabrication et de
distribution mais les PGP qui ont été
transmis à la commission d'enquête pour
un certain nombre d'entre eux
apparaissent plutôt on va dire lacunaire
donc comment est-ce que finalement
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament contrôle cpgp est-ce que
finalement vous vous priorisez des
contrôles sur les les maladies les
maladies pardon les médicaments
essentiels
quand vous constatez qu'une partie du
PGP et lacunaire ou qu'il contient
des anomalies en fait qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous faites et est-ce que
vous avez déjà infligé des sanctions
financières à l'encontre d'une
entreprise qui n'a pas établi un PGP
complet et
est-ce que ça serait pas si vous ne
l'avez pas fait est-ce que ça serait pas
utile de le faire ça c'est ma deuxième
mais deuxième question parce qu'elle se
elle se recoupe c'est sur les donc les
PGP une troisième question c'est
est-ce que il ne faut pas profiter de
l'établissement donc de cette liste de
médicaments essentiels pour hiérarchiser
davantage les attentes et les demandes
qui sont faites aux industriels
justement d'enrichir ces PGP portant sur
ces médicaments là donc en fait plus
d'exigences peut-être un contrôle un peu
plus précis et en tout cas vous qui êtes
au cœur de cette problématique comment
vous envisagez les choses on l'a déjà
dit ma quatrième question c'est sur les
sanctions financières on avait déjà eu
l'occasion d'échanger concernant lorsque
vous êtes lors de votre première
première audition mais on avait on était
vraiment au début de nos auditions donc
là ça c'est encore
documenté on a vu que finalement il y
avait très peu de sanctions qui étaient
prononcées par votre agence
qui est à l'encontre de des industriels
qui ne respectaient pas les obligations
matières
d'approvisionnement donc dans quelle
mesure maintenant vous avez la
possibilité d'avoir à analyser les
choses donc dans quelle mesure
finalement ces sanctions
sont-elles efficaces
et est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'il vous manque en fait pour
prononcer plus de sanctions et pour pour
avoir recours donc à cet outil qui est
un outil qui a été prévu par la loi
je pense que c'est important qu'il y ait
donc cet outil donc je soutiens cette
loi mais en même temps je sais
pertinemment que on demande de plus en
plus à l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament sans obligatoirement
parallèlement développé plus de de
moyens humains donc en fait là mon but
c'est pas de vous mettre en difficulté
spécialement mais c'est que vous nous
disiez qu'est-ce qui vous manque pour
pour aller plus loin parce que bon quand
je crois que l'année dernière il y a eu
seulement trois sanctions qui ont dû
être être
infligés on voit que c'est très peu et
puis on l'a déjà dit également le temps
de passage sur votre site pour savoir
que que l'entreprise est frappée d'une
d'une pénalité c'est un mois mais c'est
surtout
c'est pas très facile il faut vraiment
savoir à quel moment vous avez
sanctionné l'entreprise pour être juste
sur la fenêtre d'un mois et en plus il
faut avoir le courage d'aller fouiller
au niveau du site pour trouver
exactement cet élément de de réflexion
ma cinquième question c'est qu'on a été
alerté par les par les professionnels de
santé et notamment les médecins et c'est
venu vraiment très fortement dans dans
nos auditions en disant que il n'était
pas suffisamment informé des tensions et
des pénuries de médicaments c'est à dire
vraiment une un contraste entre
l'information détenue par les
pharmaciens et l'information détenue par
les médecins donc effectivement là c'est
vraiment
on ne comprend pas ce décalage qu'il
peut y avoir et je vais citer une une
audition mais il y en a eu vraiment
beaucoup d'autres Jérôme
médecin qui est le co-fondateur de
l'Observatoire de la transparence dans
les politiques du médicament à même
souligné que le grand public pouvait
être même informer à en amont avant même
l'existant enfin avant même les
professionnels de santé donc c'était pas
c'était pas bon parce que y compris ça
pouvait d'ailleurs déclencher une espèce
de de de
panique un peu au niveau au niveau des
Français et français et c'était pas
c'était pas bon donc comment se fait-il
qu'il y ait ce hiatus voilà les cinq
questions que je voulais vous
vous posez au début en tout cas merci
[Musique]
beaucoup madame la rapporteur pour
l'ensemble de ces questions alors sur le
sujet des stocks de sécurité en effet
comme je vous l'indiquais certains sont
à deux mois d'autres à quatre mois et
vous me posez la question du d'aller
au-delà de quatre mois juste quelques en
quelques mots très bref la philosophie
de le rational de la mise en place des
stocks de sécurité c'est pour disposer
de temps de temps lorsqu'en est fait un
industriel indique qu'il a enfin qui
transmet un signalement de risque de
tension ou de rupture pour avoir
suffisamment de temps pour s'organiser
pour organiser soit des importations
soit la nécessité de faire évoluer un
patient vers un autre traitement et donc
d'avoir
donc cela va évidemment dépendre
dépendre des médicaments
au delà voilà est-ce que au-delà de 4
mois cela paraît paraît raisonnable y
compris en termes de conservation
d'attractivité aussi de notre territoire
puisque l'objectif n'est pas d'être
heureux évidemment répulsif et qu'au
final en effet il y a un désengagement
et que la France ne soit pas considérée
comme prioritaire même si déjà ce n'est
pas toujours toujours le cas donc il
faut trouver en effet le bon le bon
équilibre et en fonction des médicaments
de l'importance en effet du médicament
des volumes aussi par exemple qu'ils
sont qui sont évidemment mobilisés
puisqu'ensuite il y a aussi le sujet des
stockage du stockage après se pose aussi
la question sans parler de au-delà de 4
mois mais de savoir où le stock est
et le plus indispensable est-ce que
c'est vraiment par exemple au niveau de
l'industriel est-ce que c'est on l'a vu
notamment dans la période paracétam
enfin les tensions hivernales sur le
notamment pédiatrique et l'amoxicilline
où on voit bien que lorsqu'il y a y
compris des stocks qui reviennent au
niveau des industriels le temps que cela
arrive dans l'officine dans l'une des
21000 officines cela prend du temps donc
il y a peut-être des réflexions en effet
amener pour savoir où les stocks doivent
être où ils sont les plus utiles en
termes de mobilisation et en termes et
en termes d'agilité donc il faut
probablement réfléchir en fonction des
médicaments en fonction des pathologies
en fonction des volumes avec toujours ce
même rationnel avoir le temps le temps
nécessaire pour trouver des solutions
pour garantir la couverture des besoins
des besoins des patients
deuxième question qui concerne les plans
de gestion en effet des pénuries avec
évidemment des éléments qui ont été
mobilisés notamment depuis 2021 avec un
cahier des charges un modèle qui a été
donc établi notamment évidemment par mes
équipes et une décision en effet donc
que j'ai que j'ai prise et qui est
public qui permettent de définir le
modèle type et donc l'ensemble des
éléments qui doivent être renseignés par
par les industriels et donc c'est aussi
des travaux qui ont été réalisés dans le
cadre de notre comité d'interface que
nous avons avec les industriels du
médicament évidemment avec un respect
total de la déontologie mais pour
pouvoir échanger en effet sur sur ces
modalités je le disais nous avons 6000
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeurs donc nous avons 6000 PGP et je
vais être très clair eu égard voilà au
moyen qui voilà certes voilà j'ai un
petit peu plus un petit peu plus de 1000
collaboratrices et collaborateurs qui ne
sont évidemment pas tous dédiés sur le
sujet des pénuries loin sans faux on est
même si c'est un sujet évidemment
important nous n'avons pas la capacité
de vérifier l'ensemble des 6000 PGP et
il faut évidemment être très clair et
très transparent pour autant lorsque il
y en effet des situations importantes de
tension ou de rupture des signalements
nous pouvons et dans ces cas-là nous
allons en effet nous pouvons mobiliser
une vérification sur les plans de les
plans de gestion de gestion des pénuries
et également lorsque nous allons en
inspection et donc notamment Guillaume
Renaud ici présent qui est le directeur
de l'inspection nous avons des
inspections très régulières pas
uniquement pas sur le sujet et ruptures
mais de manière globale en inspecte très
réglable très régulièrement les
industriels et cela fait partie en
échantillonnage de vérification en effet
des plans des plans de gestion des
pénuries et donc il y a un sujet
nécessaire de priorisation vous l'avez
et vous l'avez indiqué madame la
rapporteur est très clairement cette
liste de médicaments essentiels c'est
450 il y a la nécessité d'avoir des
attentes plus importantes y compris de
vérifications et donc par exemple de
vérification en premier lieu de ces
plans de gestion des pénuries de
vérification aussi évidemment des stocks
des stocks de sécurité qui existent
puisque c'est évidemment sur du
déclaratif mais l'important est de
pouvoir vérifier nous sommes en train de
mobiliser nos avions enfin en cours de
en cours de mobilisation de vérification
de l'existence des stocks de sécurité
sur les médicaments les spécialités donc
ils sont à 4 mois je vous l'indiquais on
en a 422 c'est en cours donc je n'ai pas
les résultats à ce stade mais on vérifie
donc on est bien dans ce système de dans
ce système de priorisation et cette
liste de médicaments essentiels va
évidemment permettre enfin cette
identification permet en effet de
pouvoir prioriser et de pouvoir avoir
une attention toute particulière sur sur
ces molécules et sur ces spécialités
donc il y a la vérification le contrôle
en effet l'existence réelle de ces
stocks de sécurité et puis il y a
également le sujet des sanctions
financières vous l'avez indiqué madame
madame la rapporteur avec un nombre de
sanctions limité jusque là en tout cas
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2022 vous le
savez depuis octobre 2022 nous avons
renforcé de manière manifeste les
critères et le niveau en effet des
sanctions financières et en effet nous
avons pu nous en avons un certain nombre
notamment en cours qui concerne
notamment donc là encore on est encore
en phase de contradictoire donc je ne
peux pas encore livrer livrer des
chiffres mais notamment qui concerne les
spécialités pour lesquelles il y a eu
des tensions importantes sur la périodes
hivernale je pense aux antibiotiques
notamment et donc avec des prises de
sanctions de sanctions financières dans
dans ce cadre là je partage donc je
partage votre point sur la publicité et
la connaissance aujourd'hui donc c'est
un décret oui aujourd'hui le décret nous
impose la publication seulement à moi
donc comme vous dites il faut bien
sélectionner son son créneau et en effet
nous ne pouvons pas aller au-delà donc
c'est peut-être aussi une réflexion même
si en effet nous communiquons et nous
indiquons c'est sur notre site internet
donc c'est en liste de diffusion à
l'ensemble sur le site de l'agence et à
l'ensemble en effet de de nos abonnés
tout le monde peut s'abonner la
newsletter de la NSM mais pour autant
nous ne pouvons pas c'est maximum on ne
peut pas aller au-delà je ne peux pas
c'est des textes je ne peux pas aller
au-delà d'un mois
voilà voilà il faut être agile donc en
effet nous mettons sur notre internet
donc ça part en liste de diffusion mais
pour autant un mois en effet en termes
de visibilité voilà
après c'est un décret les choses
pardonnez-moi de vous couper mais comme
c'est juste sur cet élément là c'est un
mois mais il y a pas une une un ajout en
disant sauf si sauf si la pénurie dure
plus longtemps il y a pas quelque chose
comme ça non maman le décret en cadre
encadre en effet de manière très forte
sinon il est considéré cela peut être
considéré comme une double peine enfin
je parle sous le contrôle de ma
directrice réglementation et déontologie
et donc je n'ai pas nous n'avons pas la
possibilité pardonnez-moi je vais je
vais je vais encore voilà là nous j'ai
sous les yeux la décision de sanction
financière prononcée peut-être publier
sur le site internet de l'agence pendant
une durée qui ne peut excéder à moi ou
le cas échéant jusqu'à la régularisation
de la situation si celle-ci n'est pas
intervenue à l'issue de cette durée
donc si jamais
ça n'est pas rentré dans l'ordre ça peut
voilà sachant que souvent les sanctions
financières sont prises puisqu'il y a
toute l'instruction évidemment du
dossier donc son prise voilà bien après
puisque évidemment il y a toute
l'instruction la mobilisation en effet
de preuves par l'industriel voilà qui
s'ouvre nous nous satisfons pas et donc
nous allons à la sanction financière et
on est dans la situation où il y a une
régularisation et donc on ne peut aller
au-delà d'un mois donc on voit bien
qu'on c'est un aspect en effet assez
restrictif donc il y a peut-être quelque
chose en effet à regarder à regarder en
terme en termes de mobilisation
d'informations d'aucune une dynamique
plus importante en termes de sanctions
financière juste je
l'objectif je pense que en tant que
directrice générale je serai extrêmement
satisfaite il n'y avait pas de sanction
de financière parce que l'objectif est
de se retrouver dans une situation où
l'ensemble des acteurs sont évidemment
sont évidemment diligents et respectent
mais pour autant
quand en effet le respect n'est pas là
il est important qu'il y ait une
sanction financière qu'elle soit prise
qu'elle soit à la hauteur en effet des
enjeux et surtout qu'elle soit connue et
publique puisque le voilà la formation
est un élément je pense même plus
important que le montant de la sanction
financière puisque voilà on a évidemment
sur quelque chose qui est évidemment
extrêmement extrêmement
impactant en termes en termes d'image
alors sur le sujet des moyens humains en
effet de la NSM vous avez indiqué que
vous ne vous ne souhaitiez pas me
positionner dans une situation délicate
donc je vous en remercie pour autant
évidemment l'enjeu l'enjeu est majeur on
a une augmentation du nombre de
signalements qui est extrêmement
important également aussi la nécessité
de mobilisation d'actions et on l'a vu
notamment sur sur la sur la saison
précédente automnale et hivernale qui
intègre de multiples dimensions à la
fois l'analyse des données évidemment
puisque en effet l'ensemble de mes
équipes notamment ici présentes analyse
toutes les données transmises par les
industrielles ce sont des centaines de
milliers de données puisque pour chaque
spécialité nous demandons les
approvisionnements donc les stocks les
ventes et les Prévisions à chaque
industriel donc quand vous avez par
exemple pour le paracétamol 30 formes 30
présentations nous avons pour 30
présentations l'ensemble des données de
stock semaine par semaine puisque nous
sommes à la maybdomadaire donc
évidemment il y a un sujet un enjeu
d'analyse des données évidemment un
enjeu donc de un enjeu ensuite
évidemment de définir les actions et
puis un enjeu et ça fait le lien aussi
avec la 5e question un enjeu
d'information donc oui il est nécessaire
il est nécessaire très probablement de
renforcer en effet les moyens à la fois
en ont mais aussi en compétences
notamment sur des Data scientistes
notamment sur la partie gestion du
risque également gestion des flux
puisque en effet quand on a une par
exemple une tension sur un médicament
voilà qui concerne une pathologie
chronique mais avec un petit nombre de
patients elle est tout aussi importante
et tout aussi critique on est on est
dans une maille complètement différente
lorsqu'on est sur le paracétamol quand
on a eu les tensions sur le paracétamol
donc les mois précédents vous le savez
le paracétamol c'est 400 de boîtes
dispensées par an donc vous imaginez
qu'on est sur une échelle qui est sans
commune mesure donc oui je pense qu'il y
a la nécessité en effet de de renforcer
et notamment pour pouvoir mener à bien
ce que nous faisons ce que nous avons
fait ce que nous faisons et je souhaite
ici solennellement remercier l'ensemble
de mes équipes qui sont mobilisées jour
et nuit sur le sujet et je ne fais pas
de sensationnalisme ce n'est pas du tout
mais vraiment mobilisé et notamment dans
l'information des partis prenantes nous
avons mis en place donc avec l'ensemble
de nos parties prenantes les médecins
les pharmaciens les patients pharmaciens
hospitaliers et pharmaciens d'officine
tous les 15 jours pendant l'apex de la
crise des réunions pour partager les
éléments c'est du temps c'est
chronophage mais c'est en effet
indispensable
j'en viens au sujet de votre cinquième
question si vous en êtes d'accord donc
concernant l'information et notamment la
sensation de disparité d'informations
entre les pharmaciens les médecins et
même aussi le grand public en effet et
on le voit bien pour anticiper il faut
avoir l'information le plus tôt pour
qu'un médecin puisse prescrire dans de
manière adéquate il faut qu'il puisse
avoir l'information le plus tôt possible
de cette molécule est en rupture et donc
de pouvoir soit par exemple si c'est un
antibiotique se reposer la question
est-ce que j'ai vraiment besoin déjà
d'un antibiotique et sinon d'aller vers
une spécialité ou une classe qui soit
qui soit disponible alors toutes nos
informations en effet sont disponibles
sur notre site Internet pour autant il
est évidemment illusoire de demander
même à l'information aussi mais un
médecin dans le temps de la prescription
de la consultation qui est quand même
courte ce qui est normale et de la
prescription d'aller voilà surfer et
aller regarder les informations sur le
site de la NSM c'est évidemment
extrêmement complexe il y a déjà la
possibilité
et nous essayons de mobiliser cette
cette visibilité d'abonnement avec une
newsletter donc pour chaque personne
chaque citoyen en sélectionnant les
items qu'ils souhaitent et donc d'avoir
un flux poussé tous les matins qui
permettent en effet à chaque personne de
recevoir ces informations pour autant
l'idéal et en échange avec les
professionnels de santé avec les
médecins et pharmaciens mais notamment
les médecins sur ce sujet c'est au
moment de la prescription la très grande
majorité des médecins sont informatisés
ou un logiciel métier et donc lorsqu'il
cliquent qu'il sélectionne en effet la
spécialité ou la molécule il faut que
l'information soit disponible à ce
moment là par exemple je suis
imprescripteur j'ai réalisé un trod et
il y a il y a besoin en effet d'avoir un
antibiotique chez un enfant de
l'amoxicilline 125 mg ml je sélectionne
en effet cet item et là j'ai la
formation de suite intégrée que cette
spécialité celle que je souhaite
dispenser n'est pas disponible donc on
est en train de travailler pour essayer
en effet de voir comment on peut pousser
l'ensemble des informations de la NSM et
donc en effet si je si je suis
prescripteur et je clique sur
amoxicilline qu'il y ait cette
information c'est un sujet de connexion
d'interopérabilité qui n'est pas
inatteignable d'après ce que ce que l'on
nous dit mais il faut en effet de
pousser en effet cette information pour
que au moment de la situation de
prescription le médecin et les
informations
disponibles voilà qui lui arrive tout de
suite amox par exemple amoxicilline 125
bien sûr amoxicilline 125 mg et bien
c'est en situation voilà il y a juste
pas un pop-up ou quelque chose voilà sur
le site de la NSM en effet il est dit
que c'est en rupture et donc de ce fait
ça permet aux médecins de pouvoir
réorienter sa prescription donc c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus efficace ça
permet ensuite de ne pas avoir tout le
temps évidemment complexe ensuite du
patient qui a une prescription qui
arrive à l'officine et il n'y a pas le
produit et donc des échanges entre le
pharmacien et les médecins enfin voilà
tout ça est évidemment extrêmement
extrêmement
inefficients et avec un seul objectif
notre objectif à toutes et tous c'est de
faciliter le parcours du patient donc on
est en train de travailler on a fait
pour voir ce qui est possible nos
données sont publiques donc ensuite il y
a évidemment des formats de données etc
mais de voir et notamment avec les
éditeurs de logiciel ce qui peut être
possible alors peut-être sur un nombre
peut-être au départ de molécules limitée
il va falloir que l'on voit mais il faut
déjà y aller expérimenter voir si ça
fonctionne et ensuite évidemment pour
que le médecin puisse avoir la formation
il faut que cela puisse être intégré et
je dirais quasiment j'utiliserai le
terme de digérer intégré pour que au
moment de la prescription et pareil au
moment de la dispensation pour le
pharmacien il a déjà des informations
avec le dépéruptures donc il peut avoir
cette visibilité que à chaque maille en
fait à chaque maillon le professionnel
de santé et l'information
digeste instantané et sans aller à
chercher de manière proactive est-ce que
ça c'est pas possible dans la vraie vie
enfin
il faut être voilà on en est tous
conscients on a un temps limité et donc
ça ne marchera pas donc il faut que ça
arrive de manière en effet intégrée pour
que à chaque étape le médecin le
pharmacien il y a cette information et
ça permet aussi aux professionnels de
santé de pouvoir transmettre de pouvoir
transmettre en effet une une information
éclairée au patient et donc ça permet un
de diminuer l'anxiété à la fois des
professionnels de santé soit du médecin
soit du pharmacien mais également aussi
du patient et aussi éviter les
sursocages puisqu'on voit bien que en
situation de tension il peut y avoir des
substockages qui sont évidemment
délétères donc ça permet d'éviter les
mauvais comportements donc c'est voilà
donc c'est vraiment voilà donc c'est un
sujet de de Plug on va dire entre des
systèmes d'infos cela n'a pas l'air
inatteignable enfin je vous parle sous
le contrôle de mes équipes ça n'a pas
l'air inatteignable alors on n'a pas de
baguette magique je suis voilà très
humble mais pour autant en tout cas les
échanges qu'on a avec les professionnels
dansaient de santé c'est vraiment vers
cette voilà vers cette voix qu'il faut
je pense je pense aller
oui parce que ça paraît ça paraît une
bonne idée
et même enfin plus plus rapide que des
perructures pour les pour les
pharmaciens puisque là ce serait dans
l'immédiateté carrément mais vous pensez
donc vous êtes en train de dire
réfléchir de travailler etc vous pensez
que que
mettre au point ce système qui à mon
sens comme ça extérieurement pareil
quand même un petit peu un petit peu
compliqué
est-ce que vous pensez c'est un délai
c'est un délai de combien de temps de
travail pour arriver à avoir un résultat
on va dire opérationnel
alors nous sommes toujours très
ambitieux mais aussi réaliste et nous et
nous travaillons en effet pour pouvoir
mettre
en effet
au moins en expérimentation
peut-être avec certains éditeurs
certains éditeurs de logiciels pour
qu'on puisse le mettre en pratique à la
fin du dernier trimestre 2023 pour voir
et notamment en période possiblement
évidemment de tension pour expérimenter
et voir ce qui fonctionne alors oui
c'est nous sommes certes ambition mais
réaliste je madame la rapporteur
connaît la NSM on est ambitieux mais
réaliste c'est-à-dire que si on ne peut
pas atteindre des choses ce n'est pas la
peine de le dire parce que sinon on
génère évidemment des frustrations et
des déceptions donc un point majeur en
effet c'est que nos données sont déjà
structurées puisqu'elles sont
disponibles sur notre site internet donc
on n'a pas cette étape supplémentaire le
prérequis est déjà là tout est
disponible sur notre site après c'est
alors je dirais pas des tuyaux en gros
c'est quand même un petit peu cela voilà
il y a des prises ou des voilà je voilà
je me suis voilà je pense que voilà si
les idées de logiciel m'entendent voilà
ils vont être mais en tout cas c'est
vraiment cela on a déjà les données qui
sont formatées qui sont disponibles sur
notre site et ensuite évidemment il y a
l'anacité de mise à disposition et donc
ça c'est évidemment important et c'est
un travail qui était évidemment nous ne
sommes pas seuls à nous ne faisons
jamais les choses seules en partenariat
avec la Direction générale de la santé
avec la direction numérique aussi en
santé donc c'est en effet une priorité
pour pouvoir évidemment mettre à
disposition ces informations qui sont
indispensables et voilà et ensuite voir
le bénéfice aussi de cette
de cette mise à disposition
d'information
merci beaucoup moi j'ai deux autres
questions ou remarques les données
dans ce sujet d'épinurie on a vu parmi
les multiples questions soulevées il y
en a deux particulières enfin en tout
cas qui vous concerne celle de de
l'alerte sur la pénurie et celle de la
veille c'est à dire que de l'observation
et les données que vous fournissez sont
souvent des données macro et vous l'avez
fort justement dit dans vos propres
liminaires vous avez parlé des
théraogénéités sans parler d'iniquité
même si peut-être que c'est un sujet à
regarder voilà peut-être qu'en fonction
de des circuits logistiques du
médicament il y a peut-être une inéquité
territoriale en tout cas on ne saurait y
répondre pour l'instant mais je pense
que c'est un sujet et que donc il peut y
avoir une pénurie dans une région voir
dans un département et dans le
département d'à côté il n'y a pas de
pénurie on va éviter de de situer les
choses de la pharmacie à la pharmacie
mais mais quand même c'est un vrai sujet
puisque pour les patients
certains sont en situation de pénurie
dans le département voisin on n'y est
pas et donc
qu'elle regarde vous portez sur sur
cette question de de la veille et donc
du coup de de du message transmis sur
les pénuries
est-ce que le message national suffit ou
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas envisager
aussi une information plus
décentralisée et je voulais réagir sur
les les réseaux sentinelles pour vous
dire que ces réseaux là n'ont pas été
particulièrement soutenus financièrement
ces dernières années on pourrait dire
même qu'ils ont été une forme de
variable d'ajustement alors qu'ils
étaient extrêmement performants plus la
disparition des dates je pense qu'on a
un petit réseau de veille sanitaire un
peu fin du territoire qui s'est déliter
depuis une quinzaine d'années et donc
est-ce que vous constatez vous un besoin
et une nécessité de remettre en place
[Musique]
un système de veille territorialisé y
compris sur le plan
sanitaire et pas que sur la question de
la pénurie je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente je
partage c'est un élément qui est majeur
l'agence a pour objectif de garantir
enfin missionné sur la garantie de la
couverture des besoins des patients et
en tout point du territoire et ça c'est
un point qui est évidemment majeur vous
l'avez souligné il y a évidemment la
nécessité d'un pilotage au niveau
national mais je dirais que jacobinisme
a évidemment ses limites et on a besoin
de cette territorialité et c'est un des
éléments en effet que que nous
souhaitons que nous souhaitons porter au
niveau de l'agence nous l'avons fait
alors notamment pas uniquement sur le
sujet des ruptures de stock mais
notamment également sur le sujet du bon
usage du médicament où nous avons mis en
place en termes de de sentinelle nous
avons en effet aujourd'hui avec une
collaboration entre le collège de
médecine générale et des deux syndicats
de pharmaciens d'officine la FSPF et
l'USPO nous avons 50 binômes de médecins
et de pharmaciens qui se sont choisis
sur l'ensemble du territoire donc dans
l'ensemble des régions compris outre-mer
donc pour être mobilisé sur différents
sujets on était plutôt sur le bon usage
du médicament mais également aussi et
l'objectif est de pouvoir les mobiliser
au niveau du niveau des territoires et
au niveau des ruptures de stock pour
avoir en effet ces remontées terrain qui
sont indispensables vous l'avez indiqué
en effet on peut avoir des tensions dans
une région ou dans un département je
dirais peut-être même une ville des fois
quelquefois et ce n'est pas et ce n'est
pas forcément le cas dans d'autres dans
d'autres donc il y a besoin d'avoir
cette vision en effet territoriale et
donc je souhaite en effet que nous
d'évoluerons des collaborations
importantes avec les ARS avec les
territoires pour qu'il y ait aussi cette
veille au niveau au niveau évidemment
des territoires avec une spécificité
outre-mer très clairement y compris en
termes de circuits logistique des
médicaments on l'a vu pendant la période
covid une situation particulière donc il
faut l'adresser de manière de manière
évidemment spécifique également aussi
avec l'assurance maladie à nouveau nous
ne faisons pas des choses seules et on
n'est pas de façon en capacité enfin on
ne peut pas et on n'a pas la main enfin
et ce qui ne serait d'ailleurs
probablement pas adéquat on a évidemment
pas la main surtout donc il y a besoin
de cette territorialité aujourd'hui ce
que nous regardons donc comme je le
disais nous regardons à chaque étape et
à chaque
à chaque maillon du cycle du médicament
et de la chaîne du médicament nous
regardons en effet les
approvisionnements au niveau des
industriels mais aussi des grossistes
répartiteurs et au niveau des officines
et également pi si on est pharmacien
usage intérieur si on est sur des
médicaments hospitaliers et donc nous
demandons aussi et nous essayons et
c'est un sujet aussi de système
d'information de pouvoir aussi avoir une
vision territoriale notamment au niveau
des officines par exemple sur le niveau
de stock dans les officines voilà il y a
des voilà des institutions des entités
notamment privées qui sont en capacité
de pouvoir avoir ces données et nous
regardons aussi au niveau territorial si
on a une hétérogénéité si par exemple
dans une région il y a des stocks
importants alors que dans l'autre avec
la mobilisation et qu'on appelle le rôle
des grossistes répartiteurs qui est
indispensable qui ont des obligations de
services publics et qui doivent
notamment
assurer en effet le rôle des grossistes
répartiteurs et d'assurer en effet une
un approvisionnement le plus équitable
possible le plus homogène possible sur
l'ensemble du territoire donc je partage
il faut qu'il y ait les deux à la fois
au niveau national sous les évidemment
voilà donc sous l'égide pleine entière
de la NSM et cette collaboration
territoriale pour en effet s'assurer et
également en fonction des spécificités y
compris en termes de typologie de
patientèle on a évidemment en fonction
des régions des typologies différentes
et donc avec cette vision territoriale
qui est indispensable c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un enjeu un enjeu majeur
nous sommes à la fin de notre Coop nous
avons un prochain Coop et cette
dimension territorialité est un enjeu
majeur pour pour moi en tout cas pour le
prochain Coop
2024 2028 oui c'est ça c'est 5 ans
2024-2028 c'est vraiment un enjeu majeur
pour pour moi d'avoir cette vision
territoriale qui est je partage qui est
indispensable très clairement
très bien merci merci beaucoup je sais
pas s'il y a des questions
complémentaires est-ce que vous avez des
remarques complémentaires à nous
apporter
merci merci
alors peut-être deux sujets en effet qui
sont alors le premier qui ne devait pas
être disponible quand je suis venu en
février nous avons mis à disposition
donc une plateforme de manière
évidemment complètement publique qui
s'appelle data point
NSM qui permet d'avoir un historique
toutes les données historiques donc sur
certains sujets notamment le sujet des
ruptures de stock mais pas que toute la
pharmacovigilance mais également aussi
les
erreurs médicamenteuses et avec un
historique depuis 2014 ce qui permet en
effet on est bien sur l'historique et
sur notre site anse.fr nous avons
évidemment toutes les ruptures qui sont
actives mais cela permet en effet c'est
un point majeur en termes d'information
enfin évidemment je considère que c'est
une valeur ajoutée voilà que c'est une
réelle valeur ajoutée et donc on a en
effet des données sur les ruptures de
stock donc à la fois en termes
quantitatif donc le nombre de ruptures
de stocks les médicaments concernés donc
les champs thérapeutiques concernés les
raisons en effet de ces ruptures et donc
ça partage en effet ça ça
participe à moi excusez-moi ça participe
évidemment à l'information et à la bonne
information de l'ensemble des publics ça
c'est le premier point j'aurai du coup
trois points deuxième point en effet et
je crois que cela a été échangé échangé
entre mes équipes et notamment et
notamment la commission
nous sommes tout à fait évidemment
disposés à ce que nous puissions vous
faire une démonstration de la plateforme
trust Med et donc pour voir vraiment au
quotidien les 3700 ou 3800 signalements
que nous avons reçu en effet l'an
dernier comment cela se passe comment
les industriels en effet alimentent ces
informations je pense que c'est
probablement intéressant de se rendre
compte en effet de de la façon en effet
dont nous travaillons toutes les
informations que nous avons la
granularité des informations la gestion
en effet donc évidemment nous sommes à
votre disposition pour organiser en
effet cette démonstration elle peut être
réalisée à distance je pense voilà il y
a pas besoin de venir in situ Carrefour
Pleyel à l'agence mais il y a en effet
cette possibilité troisième point
nous en avons en effet brièvement parlé
je souhaiterais insister et terminer en
effet
évidemment si vous avez d'autres
questions mais terminez mes propos par
le sujet du bon usage c'est vraiment un
sujet qui est majeur et il ne faut
évidemment pas l'oublier le médicament
est précieux et donc il faut qu'on
arrive à l'utiliser quand il faut pour
le bon patient au bon moment la bonne
posologie et la bonne durée et c'est un
élément qui est majeur typiquement à
nouveau sur le sujet des antibiotiques
on sait qu'on surconsomme largement par
rapport à nos homologues européens et la
situation de tension et de pénurie
l'hiver dernier aurait été très très
différentes vraiment différente si nous
avions été dans le bon usage donc on a
et je ne parle même pas enfin je parle
il y a l'antibi résistance etc donc on a
un enjeu qui est majeur et c'est
vraiment la raison pour laquelle il faut
qu'on se mobilise tous toutes et tous et
cela ne peut passer que par le triptyque
indispensable médecin pharmacien et
patient chacun a une part de la réponse
et évidemment les autorités publiques
chacun a une part de réponses sur le bon
usage à la fois sur la connaissance à la
fois sur essayer de s'écarter du réflexe
tout médicament puisqu'on a souvent un
réflexe en effet un peu tout médicament
et ça c'est évidemment un point majeur
et c'est dans ce cadre que nous
mobilisons en effet à la fois des
informations à l'ensemble des publics
des patients des professionnels de santé
pour bien bien repositionner en effet le
bon usage le bon usage en effet du
médicament l'information est facilité
notre objectif de faciliter le parcours
de soins du patient et faciliter
l'activité et le travail des
professionnels de santé avec ce que l'on
a dit pour les médecins mais également
pour les pharmaciens pour que lorsqu'il
y a une décision qui doit être prise
elle le soit de la manière la plus
éclairée possible avec les éléments en
effet dont nous disposons et quelque
chose qui est mouvant le médicament ça
bouge tout le temps le cycle de vie du
médicament voilà ce n'est jamais
statique il y a soit des nouvelles
indications soit des nouveaux effets
indésirables soit un bénéfice risque de
ce fait qui évolue et donc il faut en
permanence apporter l'information
adéquate pour que les professionnels de
santé pour puissent exercer leur leur
activité en effet dans un environnement
adéquat éclairé sécurisé pour que le
patient en effet puisse bénéficier de
produits de santé et notamment des
médicaments dans un environnement
sécurisé voilà l'analogie je le fais
souvent en effet sur
le respect des indications des
recommandations je fais souvent
l'analogie avec le ski quand on fait
quand on est sur les pistes voilà on
voilà ce qui peut être certes dangereux
voilà on peut tomber mais quand on est
sur des Spitz des pistes c'est balisés
et donc de ce fait on sait que
normalement si on s'est à peu près faire
du ski normalement on a des risques qui
sont bien moins quand on fait du
hors-piste on sait pas on ne sait pas à
quoi on va s'exposer c'est exactement la
même chose pour le médicament et le bon
usage entre le respect des autorisations
de mission de marché ou des
recommandations des sociétés savantes et
lorsque l'on est en dehors lorsque l'on
est en dehors on ne sait pas et donc
quand on ne sait pas on prend plus de
risques et d'incertitude et c'est
vraiment cela donc le bon usage est un
évidemment une dimension qui est majeure
et c'est vraiment avec les deux les deux
enjeux à la fois de la couverture de la
souveraineté sanitaire la couverture des
besoins et le bon usage qu'on arrivera
je pense tout ce collectivement à
assurer que les patients qui ont besoin
de médicaments ont bien ces médicaments
et dans une situation la plus sécurisée
possible
il me semble effectivement que vous avez
raison
d'insister sur la notion de bon usage
voire de mes usages d'ailleurs parce
qu'on sait aussi que les patients s'auto
médicalismes il y a pas seulement la
responsabilité des médecins mais moi je
fais au cours de de auditions il me
semble qu'il faut être aussi assez
attentif à
un aspect c'est qu'il ne faudrait pas
parce que bien souvent en France c'est
un peu comme ça que ça se traduit je ne
dis pas vous en tant qu'agent je dis
ensuite la traduction au niveau des
prises de décision politique
c'est-à-dire que
la culpabilisation des des
professionnels n'est pas me semble-t-il
à l'ordre du jour ce n'est pas ce ne
sont pas vos propos mais après ça peut
être aussi amplifié et la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il faut et voilà c'est la mode
et la deuxième chose parce que on a
aussi cette expérience là c'est que au
bout d'un moment pour
soi-disant aider à ce bon usage etc
qu'il y ait en quelque sorte des quotas
qui soit imposé au médecin en disant
parce que ça c'est un peu sous un champ
sous-jacent en donnant des comparatifs
ou vos collègues ont prescrit moins que
vous plus que vous machin c'est tel
médicament etc
on n'est pas on n'est pas à une course
de chevaux et donc je pense qu'il faut
il faut être extrêmement attentif parce
que le médicament n'est pas une
marchandise un bien universel on a
tendance à l'oublier et et la santé
aussi et donc voilà
et je dirais pour être un peu peut-être
en signe de clin d'oeil c'est plus
facile de demander au médecin de moins
prescrire que de s'attaquer vraiment aux
difficultés qu'il y a concernant la
production de médicaments la non tenue
des engagements des industriels etc etc
donc il faut vraiment bien équilibrer
les choses
je peux en effet merci beaucoup merci
Madame important je partage complètement
le sujet en effet
ce n'était pas du tout mes propos donc
s'ils ont pu être interprétés comme ça
je m'inscris complètement faux voilà le
sujet n'est pas du tout de diaboliser ou
de culpabiliser ou d'autres propos
d'accord de culpabiliser en effet
l'objectif notre mission au quotidien
comme je disais c'est garantir la
sécurité des patients exposés aux
produits de santé et aider et
accompagner les professionnels de santé
en fait il faut que voilà il faut qu'il
puisse être outillés quand on parlait en
effet des logiciels métiers c'est
vraiment cela qu'il puisse y avoir en
permanence en effet qu'ils puissent
avoir accès à cette information et ça
c'est évidemment évidemment
indispensable et c'est un point qui est
qui est majeur c'est aidé en permanence
les professionnels de santé les
prescripteurs les pharmaciens face à une
information qui est toujours en
renouvellement qui est toujours en
évolution voilà il faut il faut pouvoir
définir et outiller en effet pour qu'il
y ait ces informations et ce bon usage y
compris également les patients et
évidemment je partage complètement le
médicament est un bien universel c'est
un bien extrêmement précieux donc on ne
le galvaud pas d'où notre slogan les
médicaments ne sont pas des produits
ordinaires ne les prenons pas à la
légère c'est vraiment un point un point
majeur c'est précieux et on a la chance
très clairement d'avoir des médicaments
voilà on se rappelle quelques centaines
même pas que quelques centaines quelques
mêmes dizaines d'années en arrière et
donc on a des voilà on a la chance c'est
vraiment un bien précieux donc il faut
évidemment bien l'utiliser pour cela il
faut que tout le monde soit informé et
c'est notre mission en effet on a un
sujet aussi je pense de de visibilité
aussi d'être voilà d'être plus encore
connu et en effet et c'est tout le
travail que nous faisons en ouverture et
en partenariat et s'attaquer je partage
complètement à ce que vous dites sur la
production sur les obligations et
notamment les contrôles les sanctions
qui peuvent être qui peuvent être en
effet afférentes et s'assurer que les
médicaments dont nous avons besoin sont
produits à un niveau évidemment qui soit
qui soit acceptable et compatible avec
les besoins quand il y a une
autorisation de mission de marché
évidemment derrière c'est la
responsabilité de l'industriel de mettre
à disposition ces médicaments par
rapport à la population cible qui a été
qui a été définie et c'est vraiment dans
ce cadre là donc on est vraiment sur sur
ces deux dimensions
très bien merci beaucoup
au revoir bonne journée et merci pour
ces réponses assez complètes qui nous
ont permis quand même d'affiner un peu
un certain nombre de sujets notamment
le sujet territorial